[Music]  it's time for et's Kardashian catch up  Rob Kardashian's baby mama blac Chyna  took to snapchat to slam her other baby  daddy and Kylie Jenner's current flame  Tyga for allegedly not paying child  support China also called out Tyga for  telling People magazine that their son  King is quote very spoiled moving on  despite a recent report that Kris Jenner  and boyfriend Cory gamble are on the  rocks a source tells ET Chris and Cory  are still together Chris may have a  strong personality but she vibes with  Cory and he's great with the kids  meanwhile Lamar Odom is owning up to the  role he played in his split from Khloe  Kardashian Lamar confessed to Us Weekly  that he had multiple affairs with  different women while the two were  married he says it's the one thing he  regrets about their marriage speaking of  Chloe she seems to be in good spirits  today here she is goofing off with  sister Courtney on snapchat  [Music]